The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK,
let's get started.
Last week we talked
about random variables.
And this week
we're going to talk
about their expected value.
The expected value
of a random variable
comes up in all sorts
of applications.
We're going to spend a
whole week talking about it
and some of next week
talking about variations
from the expected value.
And it's probably
one of the best
tools you have for
working with probability
problems in practice.
So let's write down
the definition.
The expected value
also has other names.
It's also known as the
average or the mean
of a random variable.
Random variable R over
a probability space S
is denoted by a lot of ways.
We're going to use Ex
to denote it, Ex of R.
And it's the sum over all
possible outcomes in the sample
space of the value of
the random variable
on that outcome times the
probability of that outcome.
In other words, the expected
value of a random variable
is just a weighted average
of all possible values
of the random variable where
the weight is the probability
of that happening.
For example, suppose we
roll a fair six sided die.
So the numbers that
come up are 1 to 6.
And we let R be the
random variable denoting
the outcome, 1 through 6.
So the expected
value of the role,
we can easily compute
from the definition.
Well, there's a 1/6 chance
that it comes out a 1.
The next outcome would be a 2.
That happens with 1/6 chance.
3, 4, 5, and six all
happen with a 1/6 chance.
If I sum up 1, 2, 3, 4 up to
6, I get 6 times 7 over 2 times
the 1/6 is just 7
over 2 or 3 and 1/2.
So expected value when I roll
a die, a fair six sided die,
is just 3 and 1/2.
And as you can see
from this example,
the expected value doesn't
have to be attainable by one
of the outcomes.
You don't get a 3 and
1/2 when you roll a die.
But that's the average value.
Now the expected value, the
expectation, the average,
the mean, they're
all the same thing.
They're all defined based
on a random variable.
They all mean the same thing.
They are all different
than the median.
That's something
that's different.
So let me define the median.
Basically it is the
outcome which splits
the probabilities in half.
In other words, you've
got a 50% chance
of being bigger than the median
and a 50% chance of being
smaller.
Now precisely you can
define it this way.
The median of a
random variable R
is the value in the range of
R such that the probability
that the random variable is
less than this median point is
at most 1/2.
And the probability
that random variable
is bigger than the median
is strictly less than 1/2.
Now, some texts
do it differently.
They swap this less than
or equal to with this one.
And it could give you
a different answer
if you do that.
And I think in the text,
actually, we screwed it up.
So we have to get
that corrected.
I think we might have
put a less than or equal
here, which is not
the right definition.
So this is the right
definition that we'll use.
So using this definition,
what is the median
of the random variable that
corresponds to rolling a die?
What's the median when I
roll a six sided fair die?
Not 3 and 1/2, because it's
got to be one of the values.
The median does have
to be in the realm
of the random variable.
It has to one of the
attainable values.
What's the median value
when I roll a die?
AUDIENCE: Four.
PROFESSOR: Four.
Let's try that out.
If I plug in 4 here, the
probability I'm less than 4
is 1/2.
Could be 1, 2, or 3.
The probability of greater
than 4 is 5 or six is 1/3.
That's less than 1/2.
So 4 works.
3 doesn't work, because the
probability I'm bigger than 3
is 1/2.
So it doesn't work.
And the other definition
sometimes people use
would turn out that
three is the median.
Now, we're not going
to spend any more
time talking about the median.
What's really important in
probability is the mean.
And that's because
you can do a whole lot
more with it in applications.
Any question about the
definitions so far?
All right, so now we're going to
do a more interesting example.
We're going to play
a gambling game
and we're going to analyze the
expected winnings, the expected
return.
And this is a simple
three person game
that you can see played
in bars and informally.
But to play it I
need a volunteer
from the class, somebody
who wants to play.
You've done it.
Who hasn't done it?
Have you done it?
You haven't played.
Do you have money
in your pocket?
You got to borrow some money.
If you don't have any money,
you got to borrow some.
AUDIENCE: How much money?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I
don't know, $5 or $10.
Got it?
All right, come on down.
you're going to play
against a couple of TAs.
Maybe a couple of you
will want to play.
I'll get Nick and
Martyna to play here.
Now, this is a very simple game.
In each round, each of the
players is going to wager $2.
So I can loan you guys
some money here, I guess.
So you have $2?
All right, I have
to loan you money.
I better count this out.
AUDIENCE: I think I
can find the Zimbabwe
dollars I had here somewhere.
PROFESSOR: I don't know
if I'm taking those.
Here, you can split that up.
I loaned you guys $10 there.
You got $2.
Put it on the table.
Wager your $2.
Now what we're going
to do is they're each
going to guess the
results of a coin toss.
We'll put the pot
together here, mix it up.
You only have to do two.
You can save those for now.
Oh, that's your two.
All right, so we
have $6 in the pot.
Now, each of you is going to
guess the outcome of a coin.
So here's the guesses.
Heads or tails, that's for you.
Heads or tails,
the guess for you.
And you get a heads or a tails.
So instead of writing
it down, you're
going to sort of
hide those, maybe
get some advice from
the class, and you're
going to pick one and put it on
the table here as your guess.
And then one of you out
there is going to flip a coin
and announce the
result. And then we're
going to reveal their
guesses and the winners
split the money.
And if there's no winners,
well, they take their $2 back
and they split the pot.
So this is a very fair game.
They make their
choices, you guys
toss the coin, and the
winners share of the pot.
If there's one, winner they get
$6, which is a profit of $4.
Two winners, they each
get three, profit of one,
the other one's out two bucks.
Nobody wins, they get
their money back, profit 0.
They all win, they get
Is the game clear?
Who's got a coin out there?
You've got a coin?
Very good.
Now you've got to
guess the coin.
Don't show each
other your guesses.
And put your guesses
on the table here.
You get to pick heads or tails.
Put it on the table.
[LAUGHS]
This is not a hard game.
You got a heads
and a tails, right?
Well, yeah, did you put a
heads or a tails in there?
Yeah, there's one
heads, one tails.
No, that's blank.
You don't win that way.
There you go.
That's the tails.
AUDIENCE: I thought you meant--
PROFESSOR: Heads.
So if you want heads,
you go like that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I thought you meant
do it the other way.
PROFESSOR: There you go.
AUDIENCE: All right, I'll have
to make these indistinguishable
now.
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
One of them is
all ripped up now.
They already guessed, so they've
already done their guess.
So you pick one
and put it there.
AUDIENCE: This is
what I was originally
going to guess anyway.
PROFESSOR: So that's good.
And you now flip the coin
and tell us what it came out.
AUDIENCE: Heads.
PROFESSOR: Heads.
All right, let's
reveal your choices.
All right, so there's one heads.
Martyna takes all the money.
Just bad luck there, right?
We're going to play again.
We're going to play a few times.
But let's start recording
what happened here.
So the coin came out heads.
OK, remind me your name?
AUDIENCE: Adam.
PROFESSOR: Adam gassed tails.
And Martyna.
Is it Y?
Martyna guessed heads and
Nick, he also loses at tails.
So in this case Adam is out $2.
Martyna got a profit of $4.
And Nick is also down $2.
All right, let's try it again.
So again, pick another
heads or tails.
Adam's busily working
out probabilities here.
Well you got to put your
money on the table here now.
You got $2.
That's three.
Here you go.
[LAUGHS]
There we go.
Two more dollars.
You can make change if you want.
There we go.
All right, make your choices.
You got one?
As long as you guys don't
show him your choices,
we should be good here, I think.
And you got to pick one here.
Very good.
Can we have a coin toss please?
AUDIENCE: Heads.
PROFESSOR: Heads again.
What do we got?
All right, good job.
OK, Adam got heads and
Martyna's on a roll here.
So we got to split this up.
Can you make change
for him here?
He gets $3.
So it was heads.
Adam had heads, Martyna has
heads, and Nick's in trouble.
Nick's off another
$2 of my money.
Martyna is up $1 because she
wagered two and got three
and Adam is up $1
here for that one.
All right, let's make
another selection.
Heads or tails?
Put the money up here, $2.
Going to need another
loan here, Nick?
AUDIENCE: I can
throw in my keys.
PROFESSOR: No, no.
AUDIENCE: The keys to
my non-existent car.
PROFESSOR: You got money?
OK.
All right.
AUDIENCE: I got a lot of money.
PROFESSOR: Oh, very
good, that's good.
That's what we
like to hear here.
AUDIENCE: That's what
he likes to hear.
PROFESSOR: Everybody
make a choice.
Heads or tails?
Now, you all want
to be thinking, OK,
what's going on here?
We're going to figure out
expectations in a minute,
do the tree method.
Is there any catch going on?
Not that we would
have a catch here.
OK, put a heads or tails down.
OK, coin toss please.
AUDIENCE: Tails.
PROFESSOR: Tails.
What do we got?
A winner, a winner, and a loser.
So we got tails, tails, tails.
Nick has lost another $2.
Martyna's cruising and
Adam is back to even.
Good job.
AUDIENCE: Can I cash out now?
PROFESSOR: Well,
you're only even.
You've got to get ahead here.
All right, let's do it again.
$2.
Everybody got $2 on the table?
I'm going to have to loan.
You got money?
You got it.
OK.
See, my hope is
Nick loses track.
OK, make a choice please.
Coin toss, please.
AUDIENCE: Tails.
PROFESSOR: Tails.
What do we got?
Heads.
Martyna, Nick!
Oh, for goodness sake.
AUDIENCE: She's
psychic, I tell you.
PROFESSOR: Martyna wins again.
You didn't make a deal
with him, did you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Nick and Martyna are
perfect and Adam is down again.
Let's collect your money.
She gets it all.
Oh, she got four here.
Yeah, she made four.
Good point.
Because she won it all.
Very good.
All right, let's put
the next wager up.
Nick, if I were you, I wouldn't
do much gambling in life.
[LAUGHS] You got
any money left Adam?
AUDIENCE: I'm going
to have a big win.
PROFESSOR: There it is.
Working on the big win.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: I'm running
out of ones here.
PROFESSOR: Martyna can
make change for you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Martyna.
Do you have change for a 10?
PROFESSOR: All right.
There we go.
A couple bucks there.
And then make your selections.
Okey doke.
It's a pretty fair game.
They put the money in,
the winners split the pot.
You guys flip the coin after
they make their selections.
OK, make a selection.
Martyna has hers.
Adam's ready and Nick is ready.
Can we have a coin toss?
AUDIENCE: Tails.
PROFESSOR: Tails.
What do we got?
Nick!
Congratulations.
Nick wins big.
All right.
Tails, heads, heads, tails.
Nick, $4.
He's climbing back.
And Martyna lost for
the first time $2.
Poor Adam is sinking
a little bit here.
All right, one more.
So who collects?
Nick, do you want
to collect this?
Start paying off the debts,
but save $2 for the last round.
This yours?
Yeah, there's a last one.
All right, two more bucks.
Last round.
OK, make your selections.
Martyna's ready.
Nick is ready.
OK, Adam, what do you like?
Coin toss.
AUDIENCE: Heads.
PROFESSOR: Heads.
How'd you do?
Oh Adam, tough break.
Nick again.
Nick is the sole winner.
So he collects on the heads.
All right, so it's plus $4
for Nick, minus 2 for Martina,
minus 2 for Adam.
All right, let's see
how they did in total.
Oh, poor Adam.
Minus $6 here.
How did that happen?
Martyna is plus $6.
Now we know how it happened.
And Nick is even.
Even.
Yeah, so that's just a
tough break for Adam.
He came up here and lost $6.
AUDIENCE: Interestingly,
there's $6 on the table.
I think I should
take that and run.
[LAUGHS]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you probably should.
But I need to get paid
back from Nick here.
Now obviously this is
a fair game, right?
So how many people think
that Adam was just unlucky?
A few.
How many people think we
just screwed him out of $6?
Yeah, you're right.
But let's do the analysis
to see what happened here.
Meanwhile, I probably
should give him his $6.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And you got my money.
All right, so I have
a gift certificate,
if you would like, for
playing the game here.
You can have this or you can
have the pocket protector.
I got to say somebody's
last time turned
in this for one of these.
The nerd pride pocket protector.
So what would you
like for your memento?
AUDIENCE: I'm going
to take the box where
[? David Chena ?] is standing.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: As in [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You get one
too for tossing the coin.
So we'll pass this up.
Here you go.
Want to pass that up
for our coin tosser?
OK, very good.
Thanks very much.
Just leave the money here.
Yeah.
Leave my money here.
Oh, we took some
out of your wallet.
AUDIENCE: I got $5
money from you-- $5.
PROFESSOR: $5 from me, yeah.
All right, so leave me the $5.
AUDIENCE: This is your $5.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I should
give them back their $6.
Well, otherwise they
could report me,
and I'd be in trouble.
And it's all on film.
That would not be good.
OK, so what we're going to
do now is analyze the game.
And I'm going to
prove to you he was
just unlucky, despite
the fact that you
think I screwed him here.
So we're going to analyze
Adam's expected winnings
playing this game.
So let's do that.
So we're going to make
the tree, as usual.
Now, the first thing we
have is Adam's choice.
Now, Adam were you doing
anything besides sort
of randomly picking?
Were you trying to
psych out the coin?
AUDIENCE: Apparently I
wouldn't be able to bribe him
from all the way down here.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
you did lose most of it.
We'll say Adam
was playing 50-50.
It's a reasonable assumption.
And then we have
Martyna and then
we have Nick and their choices.
And let's say they're 50-50
as well, because none of them
know what coin is
going to be tossed.
And I'm not going to draw
this bottom half of the tree,
but it's totally symmetric.
It just gets too deep otherwise.
And then we have Nick's choices,
heads, tails, heads, tails.
And they're 50-50.
And then we have the coin.
And I'll start
drawing it down here.
And the coin can
be heads or tails.
And we're going to
assume it was a fair coin
toss back there, because
it looked like it
was flipping a bunch of times.
And you don't look
like Persi Diaconis,
so we're going to
assume you didn't
learn how to flip heads always.
So those are 50-50.
A little tight here.
Everything is 50-50.
So the probabilities
are all 1/16.
I got 16 possible outcomes.
2 by 2 by 2 by 2.
They're all equally likely.
So all the
probabilities are 1/16.
And now let's see the winnings.
So we'll take Adam's game.
It'll turn out to be negative.
Now, in this case if Adam's
heads and Martyna and Nick
are heads and the coin comes
up heads, they all win,
they split the pot.
So how much is the gain
for Adam in that case?
0.
Now they all guessed heads,
but the coin comes out tails,
so they split the pot.
What's Adam's gain there?
0, because they just
split the pot again.
He gets his $2 back.
That's 0.
Now we have a case
where Nick is tails,
Adam and Martyna were heads,
and it comes out heads.
So Nick is losing here.
The pot is split by
Adam and Martyna.
What does Adam get as a profit?
1.
He gets half the part because
he splits with Martyna.
That's $3 he put into,
he gets 1, plus 1.
Now it turns out same
scenario of guesses,
but it comes out tails,
so Nick wins everything.
What's Adam's status here?
Minus 2.
He bet $2, he lost it.
Then we have heads for
Adam, tails for Martyna,
heads for Nick.
Coin comes up heads, Adam splits
with Nick, he gets a net of $1.
Same scenario
guesses, but now it's
tails, so Martina wins
everything, Adam loses $2.
Now we go down to
here where it's
heads for Adam, tails
for Martyna and Nick,
and heads comes up, so
Adam wins the whole thing.
What does he get in this case?
Plus 4.
He wins the whole
part of 6 minus 2.
So he gets 4 net.
And then lastly, in this
scenario it comes up tails
and Martina and Nick
split the pot, Adam loses.
Minus 2.
And then the same thing
is happening down here.
Same thing.
It's just everything is
reversed by symmetry.
Now, they're all equally likely.
So what we do to compute
the expected gain
is take each value times its
probability and add them up.
So 0 times 1/16
plus 0 times 1/16
plus 1 times 1/16 minus 2
times 1/16 and so forth.
So it's easier just to add
these up and multiply by 1/16.
And when we do, we get 0.
We get 0.
If I add all these up, I get 0.
The same thing for down here.
So the expected
gain for Adam is 0.
And that is a fair game.
What do you think?
Do you think we'd go to
all that trouble just
to play a fair game?
Or do you think we're trying to
set him up and take his money?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Martyna and
Nick are alternating,
so the branch with
the plus 4 goes away.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
that's interesting.
Look what happened here.
Nick and Martina,
well, they're opposite.
That's opposite.
You don't suppose they
planned that, do you?
And how could that possibly
help that they just
happened to guess opposite?
AUDIENCE: One of
them always wins.
PROFESSOR: One of
And what does that
mean for poor Adam?
AUDIENCE: He never
takes the whole pot.
PROFESSOR: He never
Well, all right.
Let's see if that
changed anything here.
So if Nick and
Martyna are always
opposite, that means some of
these branches can't occur.
So if Martyna's heads,
Nick is tails, this is out.
So this is happening
with probability 1 now.
So these points are at
1/8 each instead of 1/16.
And these go to 0 because
that branch can't happen.
Same thing here.
When you go tails to
Martyna, Nick can't be tails,
has to be heads.
So these go to 1/8.
These go to 0.
Now, you notice this isn't
working out so well for Adam
because we're putting
more weight here
where he's got a net negative
compared to an even situation.
And here he's gone from a
positive situation, that's
getting wiped out
to a net negative.
So let's compute
his probability now.
And I'll get the same
contribution down here.
I've got 1 minus 2 plus 1
of 0 minus 2 is negative 2.
I'll get a negative 2
down here times 1/8.
In this case, I'll
have the expected gain
for Adam is going to be minus.
Let's make sure I do this right.
It's going to be 2 for the
top and bottom times 1/8
times these guys.
1 minus 2 plus 1 minus 2.
And that equals minus 2.
That's minus 1/2.
So in fact, if they come up
here and guess differently,
who knew?
Now the expected gain
for Adam is minus $0.50.
Every time he plays, he expects
to lose $0.50 on his $2 bet.
That's a lousy game for
Adam to be playing, even
though it seemed very fair.
You see what's going on here?
Now, this kind of trick is used
in all sorts of gambling games.
Maybe you've probably
played some of these games
and may not have realized
maybe somebody was
using this trick against you.
For example, how
many of you have
been in some kind of
sports betting pool?
It's March Madness,
you're betting
on the victors in round one.
It's a football pool
for the weekend.
You're going to guess
against the spread.
Who's going to win?
All right, some of
you have done that.
All right, now everybody
puts $1 into the pool.
And the winner is the
guy who was the most wins
or games picked right.
All the winners split the pot.
Now, what this says, by doing
the same kind of analysis we
just did, is that if you
collude with one or two or three
other players in the pool
to always pick differently
on all the games, it's
going to give you an edge.
Same reasoning.
When they pick differently,
it gives them an edge
and now your expected
return is bigger than 0,
at the expense of
the other players who
just go in and are
putting their picks, if we
assume each one is 50-50.
In fact, a former professor
of statistics here at MIT
used this idea, a guy named
Herman Chernoff, in the 1980s
to beat the state lottery.
Now, everyone knows
that lotteries
are the worst game around
because everybody puts
the money in, the
state takes half,
and then the winners
split the pot.
So it's a horrendous game.
Your expected return is
half of what you put in.
So you expect to lose half your
bet, because the state's taking
half and splitting the remainder
among all the participants.
Now, what Chernoff realized is
that people don't bet randomly.
They tend to pick the
same sets of numbers.
It might be a birthday.
There's only so many
birthdays out there.
Might be number of
home runs Papi's hit,
his batting average,
Pabelbon's ERA.
Who knows?
But they pick a
relatively small set
of numbers that
tend to collapse on.
In fact, if you graph
how people tend to pick.
And say you're
playing pick four,
where you pick four numbers.
And now you look at the
frequency with which
the numbers are picked.
Very crudely it looks
something like this.
Every once in a while
you get a hot ticket
where a lot of people
pick that number.
For example, if you're
picking four numbers,
MIT students might
pick 2, 4, 6, 16.
They might pick that and
so it'd be a big spike
for that set of four.
Down the street they're
probably picking in 1, 2, 3, 4.
Something like that and
there's a spike there.
If you knew this was
the histogram of what
people were picking and
you knew half the pot was
going to get split with the
winners, what would you pick?
Would you pick these?
No, because now you're splitting
the pot with 100 people.
That's no good.
You pick down here.
And now when you win,
you get half the pot.
The state always takes
half, but you don't have
to split it with anybody else.
And that means if you're
picking down here,
your expected
return is positive,
even with the state taking half.
Because so much of the money
is piled up in these things.
And so Chernoff proved
that in fact, he
didn't know which
numbers were popular.
He didn't know that.
So what did he do?
If you don't know where
the spikes are but you're
trying to avoid them and
there's not very many spikes,
what would you do to avoid them?
Pick random.
Because if you pick random,
probably you miss the spike.
You're down here.
With a number nobody would
have thought to pick,
if some random number.
And he showed that, in
fact, if you pick randomly,
your expected gain for
the lottery at the time
was 7%, or $0.7 on the dollar.
So positive even with
the state taking half.
Now, shortly after that,
you saw the proliferation
of these random machines that
we create random numbers.
Because the state wanted
to balance it out and not
have this kind of a scenario.
So now a lot of the
picks are randomly
generated in a lot
of the lotteries.
These things are not
immediately obvious,
but become very clear once you
know the mathematics behind it.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How would a
person hit a random number?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you go to
your favorite computer
and do a random
number generator.
Now, that's not
perfectly random.
People do get into
a science of this
where they're
certain cosmic rays
or whatever hitting the
earth and the frequency
they try to get random
numbers out of it
or certain kinds
of clocks and stuff
like that, the tiny
low order bits.
Actually getting really
independent random numbers
can be challenging.
A lot of the things you do
with a computer generating
random numbers, they're
distributed nicely,
but they're not
mutually independent.
And there's whole texts
that go into how to do
that for mutual independence.
Getting something that's
fair for one of them
is not too hard.
Any questions about that?
There's another example.
How many people
ever participated
in a Super Bowl bet?
OK, like maybe you're trying to
guess the over under on point
scored.
And the person who guesses close
to the total number of points
wins the pot.
And if there's a
tie, it's shared.
So in that kind of
situation, some people
figured out that the average
number of points scored
in a Super Bowl is, say, 30.
And a lot of the guesses then
will cluster around 30 points.
Now, if you knew this and you
knew a lot of the guesses,
because there may be people who
cared betting, where would you
make, say, this is, I don't
know, 40 and this is 20,
where would you guess?
You could guess here.
That's a good one.
Or you could guess here.
Not only are you not going to
share the pot, which helps you,
but in this case you'd
actually, because being closest,
you'd capture all
the scores out here.
So that's really good.
So these are the best guesses to
make for your expected return,
assuming everybody is guessing
around here because they
know that's the median.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But those scores
aren't likely to happen.
PROFESSOR: They're
not likely to happen,
but it can outweigh splitting
the pot with all the people
that guessed here.
And you get to cover more bases.
So you're right, they're
less likely to happen
because so many people guessed
in here where it's likely.
Your expected return
is better out here.
You may not be likely
to win, but your payoff
will be very large when you do.
Now, if you're in
a bet or a pool
with a bunch of 6042
students and they're all
guessing out here, well then
you want to go back home here.
Then it's better.
So it all depends on what
that distribution looks like.
All right, any more
questions about this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
if you're going
to be playing a
whole bunch of times,
and if you're only
playing once, wouldn't you
look at the most likely result?
PROFESSOR: Say that again now?
AUDIENCE: If you're going to be
only playing once wouldn't you
only be concerned
with the result that's
most likely to show up?
PROFESSOR: Well, it
depends on your strategy.
If you want the expected
gain to be maximized,
it doesn't matter how
many times you're playing.
And that can be very
different than maximizing
your probability of winning.
If you want to maximize
your probability of winning,
you're going to go right
at the center point here.
Because if you look at the
probability distribution
and say the probability
distribution looks like that,
then you want to bet
here, because that's
the maximum chance of winning.
But say so many people bet
there, you'd split 30 ways.
Well, this divided by 30 is
smaller than this divided by 1.
And so your expected return
will be bigger out here.
So two different things.
Maximizing the probability
of winning and maximizing
your expected return.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you
say maximizing,
do you just do derivatives?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, then
you could do derivatives
and all that kind of stuff.
That's right.
Once you have the curve,
you figure it out.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it
be better to maximize
your expected value versus
the probability that you win?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
In general, you want to
maximize the expected return
on the basis that
probably over life you're
doing lots of things.
And that overall puts
you in a better state.
Now, we're going
to talk about this
some next time in terms
of taking high risk
bets with high, high payoffs.
That can maximize
your expected return,
but you have a very decent
chance of losing a lot.
And so you might not
want to go there.
And we'll talk about
that next time we
talk about variance and
actually what your choice is.
Because that is a
fundamental choice you face.
Maximizing chance of winning,
maximizing expected return.
And of course, tied into
that is the risk of losing
and what kind of risk
you're willing to tolerate.
We're going to do a bunch more
examples, but before I do,
I want to show you
some other equivalent
definitions of expectation.
So the expected value
of a random variable,
you can also compute
it by summing over
all possible values of
the random variable.
x being in the range of
R. x times the probability
that R equals x.
And let's see why this is true.
It follows from the definition.
From the definition, we
know the expected value
is the sum over
all sample points
of the value of the random
variable on the sample
point times its probability.
And now we can organize this
sum by the value that R takes.
So we're going to split
this into a double sum
where here we're looking
first at x in the range of R.
And then here we look at
sample points for which R
on that point is x.
So this sum is
equivalent to this one.
Here we're just
organizing all the sample
points for the same value of x.
All right, now in
the inner sum, I've
only got values for which
R w equals x, so I can just
replace this with x.
The same as before.
Only now I've just
put x instead of Rw.
Now I can pull the x out since
it's a constant independent
of that sum.
Now here I'm summing up the
probability of all the sample
points for which R of
the sample point is x.
And that is just the
probability that R equals x.
That's the definition of the
probability of that event.
And so now my answer
is some overall values
x in the range of x times
of probability R equals x.
And that's what I
was trying to prove.
OK, any questions about that?
Now there are some
special cases of this
when the random variable
is on the natural numbers.
So the range of R is
the natural numbers.
So a corollary.
If the random variable has a
range on the natural numbers,
then another way to compute
the expected value of r
is to simply sum i equals
1 to infinity i times
the probability R equals i.
And the proof, well, it's really
just saying the same thing
here.
I'm just summing over
the natural numbers.
And the case with
0 doesn't matter
because I get 0 times
the probability of 0.
And that adds
nothing to the sum.
So I just have to sum over the
positive integers in that case.
All right, there's
another special case
of this, which
makes it even easier
sometimes to compute
the expected value.
If R is a random variable
in the natural numbers,
then the expected
value of R is simply
the sum i equals 0 to
infinity of the probability
the random variable
is bigger than i.
Which is the same as summing
i equals 1 to infinity,
the probability R is
bigger than or equal to i.
They're the same thing.
For example, the first
term here, your probability
R bigger than 0.
That's the same as saying R
is bigger than or equal to 1
and so forth.
So these are clearly the same.
And the difference
here is we have i times
probability R equals i.
Here we have probability
R is bigger than I,
with no i out in front.
So let's see why that's true.
Well, we're going to work
backwards and evaluate
that sum.
The sum i equal 0 to infinity
probability R is bigger than i.
Well, that's the
probability R is bigger
than 0 plus the
than 1 plus probability
R is bigger than 2,
and so forth out to infinity.
Adding those up.
And now I can
write this one out.
That's the probability R
equals 1 plus the probability R
equals 2 plus the probability
R equals 3 and so forth.
Probability are bigger than
1 equals, well, R could be 2,
R could be 3, and so forth.
R bigger than 2.
Well, R could be
3, 4, and so forth.
And so now if I
add all these up,
well, I get 1 times
probability R equals 1.
Two of these guys.
Three of these guys.
And you can see
the pattern here.
Before the next and so forth.
And so we've shown that this
value equals that value, which
is by the corollary just
the expected value of R.
So by the corollary, we know
that the expected value of R
equals the sum up there.
And that's the proof
of the theorem.
Sometimes it's easier to use
that top expression there.
And as a good example, it
gives a really easy way
to compute the mean time
to failure in a system.
So let's do that.
Suppose you have a system and
it fails with probability p
at each step.
And let's assume
that the failures
are mutually independent.
So if the system has
been going for t steps,
it still will fail on step
t plus 1 with probability p,
no matter what's
happened before.
And the question is, what's
the expected number of steps
before the system fails?
How long is it going to
live before you get a crash?
And we're going to let R
be that random variable.
It will be the step when
failure occurs, first failure.
We want to know what's the
expected value of R. Mean time
to failure.
And we're going to use
that top formula up there.
Makes it a lot
simpler to do that
than the other definitions.
Now, the probability
that R is bigger than i
is the same as the
probability it did not
fail in the first i steps.
So this equals the probability
of no failure in the first i
steps.
Because this event,
R bigger than i
means that the first failure
was not in the first steps,
so the system was fine
for the first i steps.
And because of
mutual independence
on when failure
occurs, this is simply
the product that we're OK,
no failure in the first step
times the probability.
We're OK in the second step and
so forth up to the ith step.
We're OK in ith step.
And this is where we're
using mutual independence,
because I've gone
from a situation where
we're OK in the first i steps.
The probability of that is the
product of the probabilities.
We're OK in each
step individually.
So that needed independents.
Well, what is the probability
we're OK in the first step?
What's the probability of
no failure on step one?
1 minus p, because p is the
probability we did fail.
So we're OK with
probability 1 minus p.
What is the probability
we're OK in the second step?
1 minus p and so
forth for all i steps.
So this is 1 minus p to the eye.
And it's usually simpler to
write that as alpha to the i
where alpha equals 1 minus p.
Because what we've got
here now is the sum.
Expected value of R
is a sum, i equals 0
to infinity of that probability,
which is just alpha to the i.
And we all know what
that sum is, right?
What's that sum?
1 over 1 minus alpha.
And that plug back in
the alpha to be 1 minus
p is 1 over 1 minus 1 minus p.
And that's very simple.
That's 1 over p.
So the expected time to
fail, the expected step
of when you're going to
fail, is 1 over p where
p is the failure probability.
So for example, if you have a 1%
chance of failing on any step,
your mean time to
failure is what?
100.
1 over 0.01.
So very easy to compute
mean time to failure.
Any questions about that?
Of course, you can do it
with the other definitions,
but the calculations are
a little more painful.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why are we summing it?
Is it like an accumulative
solution basically?
PROFESSOR: Why are we summing?
Well, that's the definition.
The theorem says the expected
value of a random variable
is the sum of the probability
that it's bigger than i.
That's what the theorem says.
So we're just plugging
into the theorem.
And then the theorem
was proved based
on the corollary, which came
from the theorem and then
the definition.
So we went through
a series of steps.
We started with a definition
of expected value, which
makes sense.
Then we got another
way to compute it
based on that definition.
And then a corollary
to that and then
we use the corollary
to prove another way
of computing expected values.
We went through a
bunch of general steps
and then we used, basically
you could use this
as a definition of this
point for expected value.
And it just says you
sum those things up
and you get the answer.
Any other questions?
OK, there's a variation
on this problem
that you see all the time
in sort of trick questions
or in the popular
press sometime, that
often confuses people.
People sometimes think
of it as a paradox,
though it's not really one.
And the example's something
like the following.
Say that a couple, they're
going to have kids.
What they really
want is a baby girl.
They get a boy,
fine, but that's not
what they're concerned about.
They want to have a baby girl.
And let's say that
each time they have
a kid it's 50-50 boy or girl.
And let's say that it's
mutually independent from one
kid to the next, which
is not true in practice.
There tends to be correlation.
But let's assume it's
mutually independent from one
kid to the next.
Now, if on the first
try a couple get a girl,
great, they're done, they
have one kid, that's it,
because they just wanted a girl.
If they get a boy,
OK, try again.
And they keep trying again
until they get the girl,
even if it's 50 kids.
They wait till
they get the girl.
And the question is,
how many baby boys
do you expect to get
before you have the girl?
what's?
The expected number of boys to
get the girl, then you quit?
So let's do that.
So we want to know.
We have the following data.
The probability of a boy is 1/2.
You keep having boys until
you get a girl, then you quit.
We're going to let R
be the random variable
for the number of boys.
And everything is mutually
independent from one child
to the next.
How many people think you expect
to have more boys than the one
girl?
You keep having boys
till you get the girl.
Most people think this.
How many people think you expect
to have fewer than one boy?
Nobody.
How many people think you
expect to have an equal number?
Expect one boy.
Good, OK, so that's the answer.
In fact, you expect
to have just one boy.
And the proof, we sort
of just did it here.
Now, in this case,
we're going to set it up
as a mean time to failure.
Same kind of thing.
Now, in this case the failure
mode, they want the girl,
but that's when you stop,
so that's the failure mode.
And a working step
is you have a boy
and you keep having the
working steps until you have
failure mode and then you stop.
And in this case,
we're not counting
the step when you stop.
So we know from that that
the expected value of R
is 1 over p, which
is going to be 1/2.
That's the number of
children you have.
And that equals the
mean time to failure.
Minus the girl.
Because you count the girl
as one of the children.
And that's going to be the
expected number of boys.
So number of children
you're expected
to have minus the girl.
This is 1 over 1/2.
And that is 2 minus 1 equals 1.
So you expect to have one
boy before you get the girl.
Any questions on that?
OK, how about this?
Some couples want to have
at least one of each sex.
They want to have at least
one boy and one girl.
So they keep having children
until they get one of each
and then they stop.
How many children do
they expect to have?
Somebody said two.
That's a minimum number.
So it's not likely to
be the expected number.
Three.
Well, OK, who said three?
Why do you think three?
AUDIENCE: Because you have to
have at least the first two,
so it can be greater than one.
I mean, one probability
is greater than one child,
one probability is
greater than two children.
And after that it's halves
which add up to one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
That's a good proof.
Very good.
That'll work.
Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about what
you were doing before.
If you were to switch your
expectations for a girl
and boy, wouldn't it come
out to the same number
but wouldn't it kind
of contradict itself?
PROFESSOR: No, if you stopped
as soon as you had a boy,
you'd expect to have one
girl before you got a boy.
Totally symmetric.
In this case, we're stopping
when we get the girl,
so we expect to have one boy.
You might have none, you might
have one, you might have two.
and as he mentions, if you put
the probabilities in there,
they will work
out the right way,
but we just did it simpler
by the mean time to failure.
And in fact, there's
also another proof,
what you're doing.
Another way to think
about how many kids
you have to get one of each.
Well you have the first kid.
And now you have this
problem, because you
want one of the other sex.
And you keep on trying to
get one of the other sex
and you expect to
have two children
to get one of the other sex.
So you have one to start.
Whatever it is doesn't matter.
And now you expect
to have two more
until you hit the other sex.
So a total of three is the
expected number of children
to get one boy and
one girl, at least.
Any questions about expectation?
OK, let's do another example.
This comes up all the
time in experimental work.
Probably all of you are going to
have some example at some point
where you're going to
do a problem like this.
And most all the time,
people do it wrong.
So let's see an example.
Say that you want to measure the
latency of some communications
channel.
And you want to know
what's the average latency.
So you set up an experiment.
You send a package
to the channel,
you measure when it started,
when it got to the other end,
and you record the answer,
and then you do it 100 times
and you take the average.
And you say that's the expected
latency of the channel.
Very, very typical kind of thing
to do, and sometimes OK to do.
So you'd do something like this.
You pick a random
variable D, which
is going to denote the
delay of a packet going
through the channel.
And there's, of course,
some underlying distribution
here, which we'll
denote by f of x.
And that's just the
probability that D equals x.
That's the probability
distribution function.
And as part of doing
your stuff, you
notice that if I
look at plot f here,
if I look at x on that
axis and f of x here,
it looks something like this.
The chance of
getting the observed
cases where I got a long delay
were small, low probability.
And almost all the time
I got a short delay.
So very typically you'll get
a curve that looks something
like that in terms
of the observations
of your experiment.
And say that you do your
experiment 100 times
and the average latency
was 10 milliseconds.
And sometimes you want
to be really careful,
so you do the whole thing
again, you do another 100 times.
And maybe it's nine
milliseconds the next time.
And that sort of
confirms your belief
that your first
experiment was valid
and that the expected
latency on this channel
is 10 milliseconds.
Sounds pretty good.
But it can be completely wrong.
And not just because
you're unlucky,
but because you're taking
a simple method like that.
And let me show you an
example where it is way off.
All right, say you
were just a little more
sophisticated about this.
And when you did
your observations,
you tried to figure out what
this curve really looks like.
And say that you,
looking at the data,
concluded that the probability
that you have a delay of more
than i milliseconds is 1 and i.
That looks like this curve,
as close as anything.
So from your data,
you conclude this.
That's a little more
sophisticated conclusion,
because now you've
identified what
you believe the
distribution is, which
is stronger than expectation.
How would you go about
figuring out the expected value
if you had that information?
I mean, you could average
the 100 sample points.
But is there any way, if you
assume this, what would you
do for the expected value?
Yeah, did I erase the theorem?
No, it's over there.
We just plug it to the theorem.
The expected delay
is going to be
the sum of those probabilities
from 1 to infinity.
So we would compute
from the theorem
the expected delay is i equals
1 to infinity probability.
Do I want to do the 0 case?
Want to be sure I don't get
caught up in the 0 case.
We'll use the case
1 to infinity.
Probability D greater
than or equal to i.
So let me put greater
than or equal to here.
That equals the sum i equals
1 to infinity of 1 over i.
What's that?
What's the sum of 1 over
i, i from 1 to infinity?
It's infinite.
Remember those harmonic number?
i going from 1 to n
gives you about log n.
Remember that, the
book stacking thing?
i going from 1 to
infinity, that's infinity.
So in fact, your expected
latency is infinite.
And you just published a paper
saying it was 10 milliseconds,
maybe nine.
So it's very dangerous to just
take a bunch of the points,
add them up, and average them
and say that is the answer.
Especially if you
have some reason
to believe the distribution
looks like this
and it really is
something like that.
It could be infinite.
Now in some cases, if your
distribution is very well
behaved, averaging
your sample points
is the perfect thing to do.
But it helps to know it's not
necessarily the case that's
a good way to go.
Any ideas what went wrong?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
What would be your
probability be over i squared?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, what
would happen then?
If in fact, it was
1 over i squared.
So you need to do this sum.
Here's a good review
question for the final.
What method do you
use to estimate that?
Remember the how do we do that?
Is that infinite?
No.
He used the integration bound.
And you'll see what
this is pretty small.
It'll be, what, 1 and
a 1/2, 2, something
like that where we can do
the integration method here.
So huge difference.
This is O of 1.
This is bounded.
Probably less than 2, if we
did the integration method.
So huge difference here
in what the outcome is.
Now, how can it be
that I've got something
with expected infinite value
and I average 100 points
and I got 10 milliseconds?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The infinite
value comes from the fact
that there is a
decent probability
that delay is going to be huge.
However, if you only take a
finite number of sample points,
then chances are
you're not going
to get any monstrous delays.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
The chance of seeing anything
beyond 100 milliseconds
is 1 in 100.
So I'm probably
not going to see.
In a sample size of
100, almost surely
I won't see something that takes
a second, 1,000 milliseconds.
But yet it's those
rare sample points
that are causing
that sum to blow up.
If I sum that from 1 to
100, I get log of 10.
Pretty small.
So I get log of 100,
which is pretty small.
So what's happening when
you do your finite sample is
you're missing
the big guys which
are very rare, but enough
to blow up your expectation.
Now, you can draw two
conclusions from that.
One of them is just we did.
The other is,
well, expectation's
the wrong measure.
And really what
we should be doing
is looking at only 1,000 sample
points or something like that.
But in practice of using the
thing over and over again,
eventually you're going
to get hit with a whopper.
Sometimes you'll see
people take data points out
when they're really
the big ones.
They say, oh, well,
that was an anomaly.
I take that out and then
we compute the average.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How much
would you pay to play
a game where the pair would the
be the latency of the packet?
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: How much
do you pay to play
a game where the pair would
be the latency of the packet?
PROFESSOR: All right.
That's a big number.
If that was my losses
here, that's tough.
I'd bet anything
up against that.
To get a payoff of infinity?
You'd pay $1,000
to play that game.
Now, you'd want to
play it for a long time
to get that big payoff, right?
But eventually that's
what it's going to be.
Any questions?
People understand the
issue here and what
to worry about when you
all do that someday?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, now here
you don't know for a fact
this is it.
But you could model and
you start seeing these.
You fill in the points and
you say, it looks like this,
let's assume that's what it
was, then here's the result.
If it looks like it's 1
over i squared, you can say,
let's assume that's what
it is and then you get
a different result. But
you take the various cases
and consider them to do it.
Or you could say, I take the
expectation assuming I never
get a point bigger than 100.
And I limit it that way.
And then you're
safe at that point
and you can get away with it.
But to blindly go out
there and say here it
is, not so reliable.
The expected value does have
a lot of useful properties.
And the most important is
called linearity of expectation.
And we'll spend the rest of
today and some of next time
talking about it.
And quite possibly it's
one of the reasons people
use it so much instead of other
things you might think about.
The theorem, and this may be
the most important theorem
on probability.
For any random variables, R1 and
R2, on a probability space S,
the expected value of R1 plus R2
equals the expected value of R1
plus the expected value of R2.
Very simple.
It's another way of
saying expectation
is a linear function.
The proof.
No, skip the proof here.
It's not hard and
it's in the text.
Follows pretty simply
from the definition.
There's a generalization for
more than two random variables.
So corollary.
For all k in the natural numbers
and k random variables R1,
R2, up to Rk on the
sample probability space
S. The expected value of
R1 plus R2 plus Rk is just
the sum of the expected values.
And the proof of that is by
induction using that result.
And the really important
thing about this
is that neither of these
results needs independence.
It is true whether or not
the Ri are independent.
Pretty much everything
we do in probability
to manipulate random variables
needs them to be independent.
You don't need that here.
And that'll make
it very powerful.
So let's do an example.
Say I roll two fair dice.
Six sided dice.
Not necessarily independent.
R1 is the outcome
on the first die.
And R2 will be the
outcome on the second one.
And I'm interested in
the sum of the dice.
So with that R
it'd be R1 plus R2.
And I want to know the expected
value of the sum of the dice
when I roll them.
Now, if I didn't
use that theorem
I'd compute the tree
in the sample space.
I'd get 36 possible outcomes,
take the probability of each.
It'd take you a
little while to do it,
but using linearity of
expectation, it's easy.
It's expected value of R1
plus the expected value of R2.
Each of these we already
figured out is 3 and 1/2.
And so the answer is 7.
So if you roll a pair
of dice, whether or not
they are independent, the
expected sum is seven.
Any questions about
linearity of expectation?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This one?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, I
mean pluses here.
Here?
I'm computing the sum
of the random variables.
So this could be a 1, that could
be a 10, this could be a 3.
So I'm compute the
expected value of the sum,
just like when I
rolled two, dice I'm
taking the expected value
of the sum of the dice.
Any other questions?
Now we're going to do a
little trickier problem that
uses linearity of expectation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sets, like when
we're looking at the failure.
Couldn't we add the two
cases, like R1 being
a girl and R2 being a boy?
PROFESSOR: Well, what
would it mean to sum-- so
what is the random variable?
R1 is the case
when you get a boy.
So it's an indicator
for getting a boy.
R2 is the indicator
for getting a girl.
R1 plus R2 is by
definition 1 then,
because you got a boy or a girl.
One of them had to happen.
And the expected
value would be one,
But that's a different
kind of game.
But we are going to start using
this in sophisticated ways
to make calculations be
easier for things like that.
so
This problem we call
the hat check problem.
And the idea here
behind this is say
that you have n men at a
restaurant having dinner.
And when they come
into the restaurant,
they check their hats
in the coat room.
Then something goes
wrong in the coat room
and the hats are all
scrambled up randomly.
Let's say a random
permutation of the hats.
So the men come back
to get their hats
and they get a random
hat coming back.
So each man gets a random
hat back after dinner.
And the question is, what is
the expected number of men
to get the right hat back?
So we let R be the
random variable
that says the
number of men to get
the right hat, their happen.
And we want to know the
expected value of R.
Now, from the
definition, that's just
the sum of all possibilities.
K from 1 to n.
K times the
probability R equals k.
So using one of
the definitions, we
could compute the
expected value this way.
In fact, if you were to
be assigned this on a test
or on homework, that's
probably how you'd
start something like that.
And then, well, the
next step you'd take
would be to figure out what's
the probability that exactly
K men get the right hat back.
In fact, we actually
asked this once before we
started doing it in class.
And it was really hard if
you went down this path.
Because if you spent all
night with your buddies,
you would maybe get
to the conclusion
that probability R
equals K is this.
1 over K factorial times n minus
K down here for K less than
or equal to n minus 2.
And 1 over n factorial if
K equals n minus 1 or n.
Then you would plug that nasty
looking thing into there.
So multiply by K. And
you'd have to sum it up.
And Lord help you.
That's just a nightmare to do.
You'd have a very hard
time getting the answer.
If you doubt that, try it.
But that would be a
natural way to proceed.
But it turns out there is a
trivial way to get the answer.
And this is a very
powerful technique
using linearity of expectation.
And for sure there will be a
problem on the final exam just
like this.
And so if you go down this path,
which is a natural first path,
it may take you the rest
of the day to solve it.
But the method I'm
going to show you
will take you a couple
minutes to do it.
Now, the trick is to use
linearity of expectations.
So the problem is
there's no sum here.
So what we need to do is
we're going to express R
as the sum of random variables.
And the way we're going
to do that is as follows.
And it's not obvious,
but once you see it,
it's easy to keep using it.
We let R be the sum
of R1 plus R2 plus Rn.
And Ri is going to
tell us the event.
This is sort of what
you were talking
about before with the event
of a boy or event of a girl.
This is going to be the
event of the ith man
gets his right hat back.
So it's an indicator
random variable.
It's 1 if the ith man
gets the right hat.
And it's 0 if he doesn't.
So whenever the ith guy gets his
hat back, that counts as one,
and now you can see
why this sum works.
R is the number of men to
get the right hat back.
And it basically there's a
one counted in here every time
a guy gets his hat back,
and 0 if he doesn't.
So this sum is counting how many
men got their right hat back.
Non-obvious the first
time, gets really simple
the fourth or fifth time.
We'll try to do a
couple of them today.
All right, now the expected
value of R is easy.
It's just by linearity
of expectation,
expected value of
R1 and so forth
plus the expected value of Rn.
The expected value of an
indicator random variable
is just the probability
that it's 1.
Right it's 1 times
the probability,
it's 0 times the
probability of 0.
That's just the
probability that it's 1.
What's the probability that the
first man gets the right hat
back?
1 over n.
There's n hats.
He gets a random one.
What's the probability that the
second man gets his hat back?
Not 1 over n minus 1.
He's coming in whether he's
first, second, or last.
He gets a random hat.
1 in n chance it's his.
What's the probability the last
man gets the right hat back?
One over n.
Doesn't really matter
if he's first or last.
Just sort of tricks
up a little bit.
He's getting a random hat back.
So it's 1 over n.
I got n of each, 1
over n, so what's
the expected number of men
to get the right hat back?
One.
Now, the math doesn't get
much easier than that.
Now, the amazing
thing is we just
proved that if we take
that mess, stick it in here
and sum it up, what
answer do we get?
1.
That is certainly not obvious,
but that is a consequence
of everything we've just done.
We've just given a probability
proof of that fact.
But the nice thing here
is there's actually
even more powerful.
Did I need to assume that it
was a random permutation of hats
like I would need
to assume for this?
No independence is needed.
In fact, there's all sorts
of distributions that will
give the same expected value.
All I need is that each
person gets the right hat back
with probability 1 over n.
In fact, this is an example
of a different distribution
for which the
result is the same.
Say you're at a
Chinese restaurant.
And you know they have
the thing that spins
in the middle of the table?
Say that you each
order an appetizer.
There's n people and they're
around a big circular table.
Everybody gets their appetizer.
Wonton soup, whatever.
And then there's always the
joker who spins the thing
and spins around
and then it stops
and now you've got a random
appetizer in front of you.
In this case, we
want to know what's
the expected number of people
to get the right appetizer back.
Not the other guys
wonton soup, but yours.
That's a different
probability space
because there's only n
sample points, n places where
the thing could have stopped.
Not n factorial like the hats.
Well, does the analysis change?
Exactly the same.
Ri is the indicator
variable for the ith person
gets the right appetizer back.
Linearity of expectation.
The expected value of
the indicator variable
is just the probability
that it's 1.
And the probability
that any person
gets the right
appetizer is 1 over n.
So the answer is the same.
The expected number of people
to get the right appetizer
back is 1.
So totally different
probability spaces, exactly
the same analysis and answer.
OK, so we'll do more
of this next time.